and you probably know me best for my
child star movies bike Forrest Gump
don't forget my famous bow but today is
a very sad day to share with you because
I'm gonna make the Halloween costume
specifically a ghost whoa
first step make sure you have a white
bed sheet make sure there's no blood
stains on then feathers the murders of
Hollywood that is that kills my soul as
a kid
second step make sure you have a good
pair of scissors that don't have blood
stains on them now third step make sure
you put the sheet over you and draw the
eyes where eyeballs are I have to do
this myself cuz I have no friends now
the fourth step is you cut out the
eyeballs for the fifth step put on your
ghost costume and go find your parents
and scary
hey guys mr. Matt but scare her scary
I said
I see dead people too
if I night I looked at the members right
now they gotta tell you there's no way
we will do this by four o'clock today
just on the card but boom Brown have to
call you back but those the good sheets
huh no where did you get these you're a
28-year old man what are you doing